belong a weighted follow-up to james
cameron's Parana 2 is finally here
piranha 2.8 d because it's not really 3d
because it's converted it is the same
converted factory line migraine inducing
3d that would make Clash of the Titans
proud have we just not learned yet but
we all know that post-production
converted 3d sucks so let's just move on
the premise of piranha 3d is pretty
simple at Spring Break and among the
beer tits ass and girls there's a school
of prehistoric piranhas that are out to
kill people and yes the only thing the
outnumber the fish in this movie are the
douchebags honestly you just look around
at one of the party scenes in this movie
and you realize that there is more
douche in piranha 3d than a bathroom
cabinet at the hef mansion among them is
the fat kid from stand by me who plays
one of these girls gone wild producer
types who tastes a group of people out
on his boat to get hammered filmed and
unbeknownst to him eaten and then
there's Elisabeth Shue and Ving Rhames
and the rest of the lake Sheriff so
we're trying to get a handle on things
and I mean you know the formula blood
death fish and more blood now it is a
known fact that this movie exists for
one reason it's gratuitous everything
drinking naked chicks blood guts it's
this movie sole purpose I mean that's
how this legit reviewer type review this
movie and he liked it and his main tag
as to why was ooh boobs in 3d seriously
I don't get how that makes a good movie
I mean just go to a strip club for the
same price you'll see boobs and they'll
be in you know real 3d none of this
post-production converted [ __ ] and if
boobs just make the movie for you just
keep in mind that post-production
converted 3d boobs can make Megan Fox's
boobs look like Cloris leachman's boobs
think of that that being said I just
can't do it I can't flip a switch in my
brain to turn my brain off so I can just
enjoy tits and violence in a movie and
have that make a good movie it's just
not me I mean tits and violence in a
movie or like gravy when put on
something of substance yeah sure okay
but I'm not gonna drink the gravy
straight up plain I just need more but
that's just me maybe it's because I
don't connect with the whole Spring
Break party thing I don't know I i'm a
nerd dude i make videos on my fridays i
mean i am not beyond understanding a
whole throwback to the 80s bloodfest
movies like the 50 cal scene and rambo i
know i brought it up before and some of
my other reviews but it's just awesome
but i mean a whole movie based around
fish killing really bad actors in
violent ways I mean whoopty so what I
mean if that is your thing then this is
definitely your movie me personally I
don't give a [ __ ] I mean I personally
hate it when people talked
in the movie but the funnest part for me
will probably be the funnest part for
you and that's talking [ __ ] about the
movie with the people you're with but
does that eclipse the shitty 3d in the
Steep ticket price not for me no I mean
I could have combed through HBO at 2:00
a.m. and found just as much [ __ ] to talk
about with my friends so however if me
and about 25 other people are at my
place when we're hammered out of our
minds I could see this movie playing in
the background on my TV so piranha 3d
gets that it's so bad it might be fun if
you're drunk award and now is party in
2d and one cameo in this movie almost
made it worth it it was a sweet cameo
that [ __ ] was legit but if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more than click right here to see more